tour de table parce que ce que vous avez
vu vous avez vu cette histoire le
journal le times a révélé que neymar
aurait imposé au paris saint germain une
augmentation pour les singles
alors il aurait demandé de toucher 1,13
million d'euros par semaine au lieu des
550 milles qu'il touche en ce moment il
[Applaudissements]
est ce qu'on peut arrêter l'émission
maintenant tu peux pas donner une
augmentation à tout le monde donc fait
augmenter une personne n'a livré qu'une
seule personne de julien de confiance
passé comme dans koh lanta d'abord vous
allez me dire pourquoi pourquoi vous
mériteriez d'être augmentée et ensuite
chacun d'un côté il y aura l'urne ici
que découvriront tout à l'heure ah ouais
trop mais celui qui aura le plus de
votes sera augmenté et on peut voter de
ses coûts mais c'est évidemment alors
qu'ils sont tout le monde vote pour toi
les invite également voteront l'adjoint
elie semoun et kelly vous faites partie
de ceux qui peuvent être nombreuses bien
sûr comme quoi on peut ne rien faire
être augmenté
et rigolade on adore alors oui pourquoi
tout simplement parce que je suis le
premier sur le pont pour préparer
l'émission vers 9 heures du matin avec
avec maria simon 2 99% des scoops de
l'émission sont apportés par mois oui
non mais dire truc sérieux quand même 2
et 3 surtout j'en ai besoin
quand on n'est pas loin pas dire
évidemment pas pareil moi dès 9 heures
du matin chez avec marine au téléphone
ensuite quand l'eau et j'en vois les
yeux et je lis des livres je les livre
des invités
ah oui un vrai argument voilà jamais
avec des invités aussi à la fois l'asie
mon spectacle c'est vrai
alors oui c'est vrai et vous écoutez les
le bolide album ce dessin l'album de
dazhou et 20 mois bob marley et connaît
pas jean michel maire en préambule que
j'adore et li na jul évidemment voilà
qu'après je veux dire que voilà c'est
pas pour me vanter mais j'ai jamais une
info donc c'est le dire que jamais
démentie donc c'est pas à cause de moi
qui ai les polémiques sur l'émission
[Rires]
c'est bien payé
jamais des hurlements comme on peut les
faire gilles jamais de paix comme comme
benjamin donc c'est un moins bon voisin
de table je pense j'ai aucune copine
donc j'ai pas de mariage en attente ni
de deux femmes à caser comme
chroniqueuse bon c'est plutôt un
avantage
j'ai jamais une proposition d'une autre
chaîne
wendy aucune ambition personnelle donc
je suis d'une fidélité à toute épreuve
donc toute façon je vis ça c'est le
français c'est pas dans mes qualités à
l'évacuer galli alors déjà je suis moins
cher et de loin donc si vous augmentez
moins cher que les autres
2 je vais à toutes les conférences de
presse rapportent des informations et je
m'endors pas pendant les projections
j'ai simplement dormir aussi mauvais
qu'ils dérapent un chef du parti
je ne dépend d'aucun groupe média donc
je dis les choses de manières les plus
objectifs que toi c'est sûr
multicasquettes magicien dj donc je sais
un peu passé certes je suis celui qui
travaille le plus puisque j'ai pas de
neuf donc j'ai que ça à faire
[Applaudissements]
déjà je trouve que ton attitude et match
c'est dégueulasse et diviser pour mieux
régner parce qu'ils vont se détester ils
ont d une famille on a franchement mine
de rien on peut pas se dépister non mais
c'est vrai on n'y arrive pas on peut
essayer au pc mais non je voterai pour
la seule femme de la table dazhou toi tu
es qui pour l'instant je dirais merci
sous la table il fait que des trucs de
ouf parce que vous vous rendez compte
que je gagne moins que le roi des
fumistes jean-michel à ce que moi je ne
fais pas de cinéma je fais pas théâtre
produit pas de documentaire parce que je
me cache pas comme certains ici pour
donner mon opinion je ferrais leur nom
par charité c'est isabelle et maxime
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
parce que l'émission c'est tout pour moi
parce que c'est ma vie parce que parce
que j'en ai envie parce que j'en ai
envie
voilà parce que il en a besoin aussi et
surtout amusez-vous
et puis derrière on veut tout rond se
monte à fatou sarr délabrés ou fait ça
avec le public jusqu'à 23 moi je suis
public de cyril hanouna je veux rester
ouverts vous resterez d'accord ok mais
pas payé isabelle et ben moi j'ai pas de
gros besoins j'aime pas cuisiner j'aime
pas l'électroménager
j'aime pas le raisonnement de rien les
sextoys j'aime pas les vêtements de
marque et j'aime pas donc j'ai pas de
permis de conduire vous n'aurez pas de
ramasser bienvenu pour un donner faut en
avoir et d'ong et de plus en plus ample
pour sa forme augmenté moi j'ai rien
compris mais bon bernard montiel 6 alors
moi il faut voir augmenter parce que
j'ai déjà les uv ça coûte cher
[Rires]
c'est ce qu'il est qu'est ce qu'ils
dépensent au point soleil celui-ci pour
moi j'ai une carte d'abonnement alors
parce que je fais des lises un public
d'abord ça fait trente deux ans je fais
de la télé et ce qui avait 5 ans quand
ils m'ont vu la vidéo gars qu'ils ont
maintenant 20 ans ils sont heureux je
l'espère de me revoir ici dans le cadre
de cette émission et que si j'allais le
dire mais une mouche à lyon et donc ça
leur fait plaisir j'espère de me revoir
ici après tant d'années ont fidélisé un
public les gens besoin d'identité comme
ça fizi c'est vrai que j'ai surtout
avant la sympathie pour moi en tout cas
moi je suis heureux d'être là et que le
public soit la houle et les gens savent
qui est une aide
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
vous méritez une augmentation alors sa
lite vous devez vraiment augmenter
dacquois ne suis jamais drôle je déteste
me déguiser je suis complètement bidon
en happening je vous fatigue avec des
livres en permanence donc rien que pour
ça merci augmenté mois sur les environs
de miss france tu sais et je veux que
boîte alors moi ça fait sept ans que je
des rushes tous les offres de ses
missions car est donc maintenant je
connais très très bien tous les rouages
je sais qu'il ya une seule chose qui
marche si si c'est le chantage j'ai
vraiment des dossiers deux fois plus de
monde que je n'ai jamais manqué même
sûrement évidemment sur la bande en
caressant sa revanche que tous vous
faire tomber donc voudrait bien mener
augmenté mais vite
[Rires]
cette mesure lui confère des gens petits
cadeaux c'est qu'il ya votre nouvelle
émission qui démarrera le 28 mars
prochain
très beau succès vite et on a des images
exclusives à vous montrez vous on va
regarder des images d'après qui les
chassent il a été payé pour cette
émission il appellera une augmentation
assez normalement cessé pour sa bien
aimée dans ce samedi que la sardine quel
légume ressemble plus à stéphane bern
possible il a une tête à ça tu es
comment un prénom américain mais pour un
français qui fait jouer dans la vie
chère dans les yeux vous faisiez un
sketch me parler d'explosion de foufoune
[Applaudissements]
dans l'ue
et on oublie l'augmentation pourquoi
vous augmenterez alors moi il faut
augmenter
cyril jeu celle qui arrive le plus tôt
dans l'émission je suis la première à
arriver tous les jours mais pour faire
quoi cgt explique jean luc tu là pour
l'adar ko s'éclate on chante on danse
j'essaye d'être de bonne humeur tous les
jours et jack vous c'est vrai je vous
aime et on s'éclate voilà oui c'est vrai
mais je pense que pour ça mais pas de
moi mais là les photos de tous ces
jeunes seraient toutes boîtes à rythmes
et comme max j'ai le plus petit salaire
donc ce serait cool ça dépassera pas les
autres et elle arrive si tôt si c'est
parce que quand on arrive c'est le sosie
de liberté après ya beaucoup de travail
alors oui chérie nous aller voter chacun
votre tour vous voter pour la personne
qui mérite une augmentation et je vais
dépouillé ici on peut pas voter - soir
mais d'aller me remettre et ne pouvaient
pas voter pour mondial est venu remettre
mon sens le papier ils ont tous voté
pouvait pas rater pour l'un d'entre eux
pas pour eux-mêmes pour savoir qui aura
une augmentation pour l'instant on sait
que nick est en tête
est ce parce qu'on peut voir le tableau
dans la 2 votes à la de vote
maxime avec un coeur en fête et des
larmes ça c'est un truc de psychologues
là pour être ici mais je ne sais pas qui
c'est maxime donc vous méritez une
augmentation jean-michel pigeon qui on
avait dit qu'on va est pour toi et moi
c'est toi qui a voté pour jean michel
naud personnes au bassin disque rihanna
qui a voté lors du sommet il réalise
qu'on veut de bois se dire c'est comme
ça que c'est plus creux et moi c'est
vous oui quelle horreur je tiens à dire
que j'avais voté pour maxime vont plus
malheureusement je regrette c'est que
les assassins a bien voté pour moi moi
moi j'ai voté pour jean tuffou quelqu'un
qui veut une augmentation pour d'être
joué il est déjà double disque de
platine mais là ya fait sa voix c'est
isabelle a pas beaucoup
[Applaudissements]
c'est quoi ça parle d'augmentation c'est
moi le juif mais j'ai le vrai vote issa
mahdi
la demande est là qu est je le mets à
part cela c'est une cote de tête à deux
mains ça serait si la tension
il reste trois bulletins pour la sto 2
pour kelly 2 pour benjamin en tout cas
bernard émond nous aime bien bon après
si max à à maxime gagné 24 gougerot un
jeu qu'elle a dit qu'aller voter pour
maxime accès pas maximois intentions
elle a dit regretter elle peut changer
non deux il reste deux boutons de votre
le public sur twitter
est ce qu'on peut avoir la vie du pays à
les voir pour qui ils ont voté avant de
voir ces deux derniers votes mais ils
ont voté pour le public c'est maxime qui
dit qu'avec des taux qui est à et mérite
d'être augmentée attention donc cru
qu'on peut
benjamin benjamin évolution le talent
est reconnu dans votre boîte décisif un
dernier vote ici c'est maxime ou kelly
se serait c'est moi qui vais décider
toujours à 3 votre partout et je
déciderai oh là là qui est augmentée
donc servi à rien ce vote finalement si
au final vous décidez aurait pu lier du
ton jour viendra peut-être pas tort mais
c'est valérie c'est benjamin castaldi
[Applaudissements]
s'est passé était benjamin matheaud si
nous écoute vous avez choisi c'est moi
qui gagne alors qu'amiens mer 50 euros
par mois c'est génial s'allumant ce
duvet je vous jure 50 euros par mois
d'augmentation de capital
[Applaudissements]